[Musique]
la désinformation est intiment liés au
déroulement même du conflit actuel en
ukraine dans le camp des pro russe une
nouvelle tendance a commencé à être
observé par les experts celle des
fausses vérification de fait défaut fac
checks un type de désinformation autant
sur réel que pernicieux d'abord et avant
tout présente sur le réseau télégramme
ces fausses vérification de fait gagner
en popularité tout en alimentant encore
plus la confusion qui règne autour de
cette guerre
nicolas des fausses vérification de fait
je pensais pas à voir ça de sitôt
c'est comme les fausses nouvelles
prochaine génération mais dans le
contexte actuel du conflit en ukraine
dit non appelé en quoi ça consiste
mais ce convoi qui circulent sur le web
c'est comme tu dis des fausses
vérification de fait qui démentent des
vidéos photos supposément des tournées
qui sortent du camp pro et craignait
donc un peu comme ce qu'on fait ici on
décrit peur on dit bon à cette photo-là
circulent cette vidéo la circulent c'est
faux voici pourquoi mais ce qui est
particulier avec ça c'est ce qu'ont
découvert des chercheurs des jo frenzic
ce risque là ainsi que des journalistes
du média pro publica c'est que dans bien
des cas ces photos et vidéos là n'ont
pas circulé sur le web avant de faire
l'objet de vérifications de fait à bord
ce qui veut dire donc pas de viralité ya
pas de viralité c'est carrément créé de
toutes pièces dans le but faire cette
vérification de faire donc c'est une
campagne d information
camouflé en vérification fait et c'est
souvent
propagées par des comptes pro russes ou
encore des médias d'état russe comme
arte ok c'est plus sophistiqué élaboré
que je pensais parlons maintenant des
cibles visées du public visé c'est la
population rouge précieux mais c'est
surtout la population russe
effectivement on voit surtout ça
circuler dans des chaînes télégramme en
russie dont télégramme une application
de messagerie assez populaire là-bas
dans un but vide blanc de désinformer de
changer un peu
le discours ambiant sur la garde à faire
douter le narratif de famille narratif
de faire douter des images qu'on voit
peut-être qu'ils sortent de l'ukraine de
faire penser que ça va mieux en ukraine
que quinconque on le prétend il y en a
qui vise également un public occidental
il ya des tweets qui ont été faits par
des ambassades de russie par exemple
dans plusieurs pays qui propageraient
ces fausses de vérification de ferrer
mais c'est beaucoup moins virale quand
on vise un public a réussi une chaîne
télégramme en particulier qui s'appelle
en fait où la guerre d un faux accent
français cette chaîne télégramme là
encore une fois en russe qui a plus de
700 mille abonnés depuis sa création le
23 février donc lavé de l'invasion en
russie et
cette chaîne télégramme la sq ont trouvé
des jo frenzic ce mr jobs c'est qu'elle
sait même métamorphose est un site web
qui s'appelle the world fixe point com
et ce site web disponible en cinq
langues anglais français mandarin
espagnol et arabe en russe et sur le
site on dit que le sénat était partie
par des administrateurs de chêne
télégramme non politique en russie donc
des personnes neutres qui veulent juste
nous nous présenter les faits sur cette
cette guerre en russie parce qu'il me
semble-t-il une campagne d information
qui vise la russie mais quand on regarde
les vérifications de fait qui se font
elles vont toutes dans le même sens
elles sont toutes pro-russe et on se
sert de termes comme par exemple
opération militaire spéciale on parle
pas d'invasion ou de guerre en russie
dont on peut douter de la neutralité de
la chose dont je parlais avec ingrid de
kensington chercheurs diderot fredricks
research lab qui s'est penché sur down
fixe qui dit que ça semble être une
opération coordonnée organisé parce que
la chaîne télégramme russe leur part de
700 mille abonnés c'est quand même
substantielle lycée une croissance
vraisemblablement organique s'est pas
manipuler parce que la chaîne est promu
justement par des personnes proches du
pouvoir en russie par des médias d'état
russe comme arte donc il ya une
croissance fulgurante qui se font à un
mois qui semble réelle mais on ne va pas
jusqu'à dire que c'est une opération de
l'état russe pour plusieurs raisons
rennes
donc tout ça iman de moscou maintenant
si on y allait un petit peu plus
concrètement un hélico la donner des
exemples de type de fausses vérification
de fait voies il ya plusieurs sortes un
exemple bien concret c'est une vidéo
d'un char d'assaut
russes qui en train de se faire détruire
donc on voit le char en creux avec la
lettre z qui l'identifient dessus mais
ce que dit la fosse vérification de fait
c'est que c'est une vidéo qui a été
manipulée qu'en fait elle a été tournée
en 2014 dans le dos bas c'est que le z a
été rajouté par la suite grâce à un
logiciel de montage voici pour donner
l'impression visiblement que ne savais
pas aussi mal qu'on dit en ukraine pour
les forces russes mais ce qu'a remarqué
propublica ce que cette vidéo là avant
de faire l'objet de vérifications de
fait l'homme qui était partagé tant sur
des comptes twitter l'ambassade russe
que sur down fait que dans des chaînes
télé gamme mais elle a jamais circulé
avant de faire l'objet d'une
vérification de fleurs qui visiblement
avait plein temps avec pour but de dire
aux gens faites attention à ce que vous
voyez c'est de faire douter les gens
flamande avait réussi parce qu'ils
voient c'est ça qui dangereux avec
exactement puis justement on fait avec
toutes sortes de moyens le tout sur de
fausses vérification on voit d'autres
photos de gens par exemple qui sont
blessées dans les explosions est ce
qu'on voit dans les fosses de
vérification de fesses car non seulement
ces gens là si les acteurs c'est pas
vraiment les gens blessés donc c'est
pour remettre en question les
informations qui sortent de l'ukraine
vit donc ses fausses vérification de
fait manufacturés créé de toutes pièces
est-ce qu'on mesure nicolas je sais que
c'est assez récent comme phénomène de
mesurer leur efficacité dans établir la
porte et ce que dit ingrid baeck henson
ne sait que ce mécanisme soit de
vraiment copier
l'identité visuelle de vérificateurs de
fait de prendre cette crédibilité là qui
a été établi au fil des ans par des
organismes de vérification de fait comme
des entités neutre mais entité fiable
après effectivement d informer de
manière efficace et
semer le doute créer la confusion on le
voit très bien c'est ça l'objectif
et puis c'est un nouveau front un qui
s'ouvre sur la lutte contre la
désinformation nicolas va falloir
surveiller ça